perhaps you're thinking of investing in
a wind farm on the Great Plains or solar
plant in the southwest after all these
are places in the United States that get
the most wind and Sun so they will
obviously produce more electricity and
perhaps are the best way to help the
environment but our displace is really
the best ones to save the environment to
answer this question you must first
answer a question of your own why are we
increasing the amount of electricity
produced by renewable energy sources if
our goal is to save the environment by
reducing air pollution and carbon
emissions where you build those plants
makes a difference while investing in
wind farms and solar plants in
California is helpful the environmental
benefits are substantially greater if
you invest in those implants in western
Pennsylvania Ohio and West Virginia that
is because the electricity used in these
regions is based on coal while in
California it is based on energy sources
with less air pollution emissions like
natural gas the differences can be
substantial a wind turbine in West
Virginia this place is twice as much
carbon dioxide and seven times as much
health damages from air pollution as the
same turbine in California
unsurprisingly the benefits of solar
plants are the greatest in the cloudy
East as opposed to the sunny south west
because in many of the locations in the
East there is a lot of generation from
coal and also because of population
density this might change in the future
however as we switch from power plants
using coal to those using natural gas or
other low-carbon electricity generation
so before you make decisions on where to
locate renewable infrastructure whether
as an individual company or policymaker
you ought to consider where that
investment will reduce air pollution and
greenhouse gas emissions the most at
carnegie mellon university Scott
Institute for energy innovation we are
helping policymakers and consumers make
wise decisions based on scientific and
technical information you can help
you